("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Beachside" by Bazanji)
Went to the Knicks game.
That was most of my day.
It's MLK Day honoring an
amazing man which is great.
Then I caught up
with Kelly McCarthy.
Who's a senior digital
marketing executive at Nike.
Catching up with
Kelly for drinks.
My favorite.
Fun fact a lot of you don't know
besides AJ the biggest impact on
VaynerMedia in the early days.
I miss her so much.
She's at Nike.
We're drinking wine,
life is good.
That was a lot of fun.
Strategizing the future.
And now I'm going to sit down
and this is gonna be
the meat of the episode.
It's gonna be a
meeting with Rich The Kid.
A young man who's been
able to really hack culture,
especially in the hip hop world.
Fascinating guy and
gonna give him some
thought starters for
some opportunities.
Shoot the shit a
little bit, jam.
As you guys can
tell I've been really
digging deep in to culture.
Right now narrowing in on
hip hop quite
a bit but have been
also spending some time with
obviously athletes with the
VaynerSports thing.
Most of it's been
behind closed doors.
And then Instagram
influencers, right?
Just spending enormous amount
of time understanding the people
that have 250,000 followers or
more that are following me.
Hit up a bunch of them
on DM over the weekend.
Biz deving, trying to
come up with collaborations,
different ways to
provide each of the value.
For me, I continue
to crave exposure.
Looking for as many people to
know what I'm up to because
I've been noticing the
conversion's very high
once people get
aware of my stuff.
20% hate me 'cause they
think I'm too egotistical,
too much bravado,
too loud, too East Coast.
80% are obsessed with
it and then of that 80%,
50% so 40% are able to hold on
and actually put it to good use
and 10% of that, so
4% of my exposure,
they really execute and
their lives really change
and that is intoxicating.
I am very much lately on this
mission of realizing I'm gonna
get mine now if I can really
help tens if not hundreds of
thousands of
people getting theirs.
What does that look
like in a decade?
What if in 10 years I'm
partially or substantially
responsible for hundreds of
thousands of people who have
10, 50, 100 X
their lives, their happiness,
their fortunes?
Makes me feel that they'll be a
lot of biz dev
opportunities in 2027.
And so, it's an incredible
feeling and reminds me of doing
the right thing is
always the right thing.
And so just got off the phone
with one of the five biggest
golfers in the world.
That was fun especially 'cause
Nate and Tyler and AJ a lot of
characters around me
are big golfing fans.
And just trucking
along, you know?
Here we are, you know, 8:22
meeting hasn't even started yet.
MLK day is a day where a lot of
people have been calling it a
non-day working wise and if they
have they've packed it in a long
time ago and I'm proud, I'm very
proud that I'll be here grinding
until 11 P.M. doing my thing.
I think it separates me
from a lot of people.
A lot of people try to figure
out why this is happening.
And sure, charisma and smarts
and natural talent is a factor
but don't ever get it twisted,
I'm out fucking working you and
that is a major
part of the equation.
And you can do that
to your competitor.
It is the most controllable
aspect in this
warfare of business.
And for me, I can't make
myself much more talented.
I can't control a lot
of the serendipity.
I can control the hours I put
in and that feels intoxicating.
("Mannequins" by Bazanji)
What up, my man?
- [Rich] What's going on?
- Good to see you, my man.
Thanks for coming up.
'Sup, my man? Gary.
- [Carl] I'm Carl.
- Carl. Real pleasure my man.
- [Jay] Jay.
- Jay, what up, man? Gary.
Real pleasure.
Gary.
- [Luke] Luke.
- Pleasure, come on in.
I watched a whole
world in every genre.
- Yeah.
- And there's not a lot of
people that understand how to
cut through culture.
You figured it out.
I'm impressed.
And what's scary is, and
that's what I want to talk about
tonight, what's scary
is it's just starting.
The key is always to have a
streets fucking with you.
That's the leverage.
Always. In business.
Even more than in music.
It's all people care about.
(censored) is, they
don't think you're funny.
They don't like your hair.
- [Rich] Right.
- They want your attention.
They want people that fuck
with you want to fuck with them
'cause you fuck with them.
That's it.
And the second you don't
have that person's attention,
they're thrilled.
They're thrilled that
you lost that leverage.
They're happy.
They're like fuck you.
Another thing that you want to
think about build out
all your platforms.
Never be at the
mercy of something.
If Instagram fucks up or starts
fading you want to make sure you
have other places.
So when you hear new
shit, oh this new Snapchat.
What a lot of people do when
they're dominating something
like Instagram or the
old Twitter like nah,
that's not good because they've
made the bed on Instagram.
Make sure you're
fucking big on everything.
Taste everything,
try everything.
You hear kids talk
about House Party, good.
Sign up, try it.
You hear kids talk
about Musical.ly,
good try it.
And it doesn't
matter if it goes away.
Vine came and went, I made
money while it was around.
("Mannequins" by Bazanji)
Like hip hop people,
like now hip hop kids are gonna
be hundred millionaires 'cause
they're getting out.
They're playing at
the highest levels.
Just like athletes.
You go back to
the '60s and '70s,
athletes they had
jobs in the off-season.
- [Carl] Right.
You're right.
- Like the biggest
quarterbacks in the '50s,
'60s, '70s they hope to
coach when they were done.
Now these quarterbacks
they want to own the team.
You know hip hop kids coming
up 20 years ago they're like
"Oh, maybe I'll get
like a good deal."
Now they want to own the label.
They want to own
a fashion brand.
Sneaker deals.
Startup companies.
Everybody's in for
whatever and that's huge.
That's game changing.
- [Carl] Exactly.
Exactly.
- I'm just trying to get
youngsters to realize don't
worry about the President,
don't worry about anything.
Just do your thing.
Stay laser focused.
Like shit's gonna happen
around you regardless.
No matter how
popular you are,
you're not changing
who the President is.
No matter how popular we are
you're not gonna change who ever
wants to be a
racist or a sexist.
Just do you.
- [Carl] Exactly.
Can't change it.
- People spend too much energy
worrying about what
they can't control.
Only way guy like you get to the
next step is only two ways one
ultra talented,
you got the shit, fuck it.
You good enough, that's it.
That's the truth.
It's sports.
You could be the
biggest fuck face,
go in, if you got so much
talent you're eventually gonna
get to the league.
But how you stay,
that's a whole different story.
How you make it to
that second contract,
that real money.
You're still better
of trying and losing
than not trying at all.
Trying shit,
pushing those boundaries,
people don't get it.
If you lose over
time people forget.
If you hit, you're a pioneer.
People don't
understand how America works.
You're better off going one
for five than going oh for oh.
("Mannequins" by Bazanji)
- Nice meeting you.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
Good luck.
My man, good luck to you.
Take care, my friend.
Thank you so much.
We'll talk more.
- [Rich] Sure.
- [Gary] Just wrapping
up another meeting.
Biz dev life until I die.
(Gary and DRock laugh)
That's really what
it is though, guys.
Shaking hands, making
opportunities happen.
You know, we go
through patterns, right?
If you look back
at these episodes.
Obviously, I'm scratching itches
right now around this hip hop
community, the culture,
the emerging hip hop
artists and trendsetters.
I do believe that the
emergence of social.
I think we're in a very
interesting spot right now where
I think the maturity of the
young music
future players is different.
Smarter and at least, not
smarter just relevant for where
I see a 2019, 2022 world and
so I'm spending time learning.
I'm spending time
bringing value.
Value exchange
forever and so late nights,
worth it.
See you tomorrow.